- Vítej zpět v kurzu „Porozumění kvantové
informaci a výpočtům." Jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický ředitel
pro IBM Quantum Education.
Toto je pátá lekce série a zároveň první lekce
druhé části série, která se věnuje kvantovým algoritmům.
V této části budeme zkoumat
výpočetní výhody kvantové informace, tedy se podíváme na to, co můžeme dělat
s kvantovými počítači a jaké výhody by kvantové počítače potenciálně mohly mít
oproti klasickým počítačům.
Zaměříme se na to, co můžeme dělat s jediným kvantovým počítačem, na rozdíl od distribuovaného
prostředí, například
kde více kvantových počítačů vzájemně komunikuje přes nějakou síť.
V distribuovaných prostředích skutečně existují kvantové výhody, kde hraje roli komunikace a
kryptografie,
ale v této části o těchto věcech
nebudeme mluvit.
Tato část pojednává o kvantových algoritmech běžících na jednotlivých kvantových počítačích.
Začněme přirozenou otázkou. Jaké výhody by kvantový
počítač mohl potenciálně nabídnout?
Hlavní výhodou je, že kvantové počítače by mohly poskytovat rychlejší řešení některých výpočetních problémů.
Čas je vzácný, a i když počítače, které
každý den používáme, jsou poměrně rychlé, jsou stále příliš pomalé
na řešení určitých výpočetních problémů kvůli inherentní
výpočetní obtížnosti těchto problémů.
Tento potenciál, že kvantové počítače by nám mohly umožnit řešit problémy, které jsou pro klasické počítače
příliš pomalé,
je skutečně to, co hnalo
výzkum kvantových algoritmů po několik posledních desetiletí.
Existují i jiné výpočetní
zdroje kromě času, které lze vzít v úvahu, například množství počítačové paměti potřebné pro výpočty,
ale ukázalo se, že kvantové počítače
nemohou nabídnout příliš velké úspory z hlediska paměti, a klasická počítačová
paměť je poměrně levná
zejména v porovnání s kvantovou pamětí. Takže zde
není příliš velký příslib.
Mohli bychom také uvažovat o jiných zdrojích, jako je množství energie
potřebné pro výpočty, ale ve skutečnosti na klasické výpočty nepotřebuješ
příliš mnoho energie
zejména pokud jsi ochoten
věci zpomalit.
Takže naším hlavním zaměřením je skutečně čas
potřebný pro výpočty.
Zde je přehled lekce, která pojednává o specifickém
modelu výpočtu známém jako dotazovací model.
Tento model si můžeš představit jako Petriho misku pro rozvoj algoritmických nápadů, jak kvantových, tak klasických.
Není zamýšlen jako praktický model popisující druhy
výpočetních problémů, se kterými se setkáváme v reálném životě.
V dalších lekcích této části se od dotazovacího modelu odkloníme a zaměříme se místo toho na modely motivované praktičtějšími
pojmy výpočtu,
ale dotazovací model je
velmi dobrým výchozím bodem.
Je to jednoduchý model, který nám umožňuje zkoumat
potenciál kvantových počítačů bez velkého množství technických
detailů v cestě,
a také nám umožňuje izolovat některé
z opravdu důležitých myšlenek za kvantovými výpočty a tím, jak fungují.
Kvantové výpočty se skutečně nejprve rozvíjely v tomto modelu a myšlenky, které v něm
byly vyvinuty, velmi přímo inspirovaly
důležité kvantové algoritmy
jako je Shorův algoritmus pro faktorizaci.
V první části lekce se podíváme konkrétně na to, co je dotazovací model výpočtu,
a ve druhé, třetí
a čtvrté části probereme tři
kvantové dotazovací algoritmy, konkrétně Deutschův algoritmus,
algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa
a Simonův algoritmus, které odhalují stále
působivější výhody
kvantových počítačů
oproti klasickým počítačům v rámci dotazovacího modelu výpočtu.
Abychom vysvětlili dotazovací model výpočtu, začněme nejprve standardnější
abstrakcí výpočtu.
Zde je obrázek, který
představuje výpočet ve velmi jednoduchých a základních pojmech.
Máme vstup, který obvykle nabývá
podoby binárního řetězce, i když bychom mohli použít i jiné
symboly, kdyby se nám chtělo.
Vstup je poskytnut výpočtu, který je reprezentován modrým
obdélníkem na tomto obrázku,
a výsledkem výpočtu je, že se produkuje nějaký výstup, opět nejčastěji
binární řetězec.
Tento obrázek samozřejmě
vůbec nespecifikuje, jak výpočet sám funguje.
Můžeme formulovat různé
specifické výpočetní modely, například Turingovy stroje
a Booleovský circuit,
nebo kvantové circuit, pokud uvažujeme o
kvantových výpočtech.
Je pravda, že tento obrázek
nepředstavuje skutečnost, že mnohé z počítačů, které každý den používáme, nepřetržitě přijímají
vstup a produkují výstup,
v podstatě interagují s námi a s jinými počítači například přes
internet.
Ale tyto interakce se zde
nesnažíme reprezentovat.
Jde o modelování
izolovaných výpočetních úkolů.
Například vstupem může být
binární kódování čísla nebo reprezentace matice
WEBVTT
nebo popis molekuly nebo v podstatě cokoliv jiného, co máme na mysli, a existuje nějaký výpočetní úkol
prováděný pouze na tomto vstupu.
Klíčovým bodem je,
že celý vstup je poskytnut výpočtu a nic ze vstupu
není před ním skryto.
Dotazovací model
výpočtu funguje jinak.
V dotazovacím modelu je vstup zpřístupněn
ve formě funkce, ke které může výpočet
přistupovat pomocí dotazů,
jinými slovy vyhodnocováním funkce
na různých vstupech.
Zde to můžeš vidět znázorněno
ve formě obrázku.
Podobně jako předtím, výpočet je reprezentován
modrým obdélníkem, ale místo toho, aby přijímal vstup přímo
ve formě řetězce
bitů, přistupuje ke vstupu efektivním kladením otázek
a přijímáním odpovědí.
Někdy používáme
pojmy oracle a černá skříňka pro označení mechanismu,
který poskytuje vstup.
V teorii složitosti existuje rozdíl mezi
oraclem a černou skříňkou, ale to nebude pro účely tohoto výkladu vůbec relevantní.
Každopádně, tyto pojmy mají
vyjadřovat základní myšlenku.
Ve starověkém Řecku jsi
mohl jít k oraklovi, například k věštírně v Delfách,
a položit důležitou otázku,
a oracle by odpověděl
na tu konkrétní otázku, ale rozhodně by ti neřekl vše, co věděl.
Podobně, když
uvažujeme o černé skříňce, máme na mysli jakýsi
proces nebo systém,
kde můžeme zvolit, co vstupuje, a vidíme, co vystupuje, ale nemáme žádné pochopení
jeho vnitřního fungování.
A to je případ zde. Vstup do problému
nabývá podoby funkce a vše, co můžeme dělat, je
vyhodnotit tuto funkci,
ale jinak nemáme
žádné znalosti nebo pochopení toho, jak funguje.
V celé lekci
si vyhradíme písmeno f pro funkci, která
reprezentuje vstup, a předpokládáme,
že vždy nabývá
podoby, kterou vidíš právě zde.
Sigma označuje binární abecedu, takže f je funkce z řetězců
bitů do řetězců bitů,
a konkrétně předpokládáme,
že vstup f je řetězec bitů délky n a výstup je řetězec
bitů délky m,
kde n a m jsou kladná celá čísla.
Pro různé problémy budeme
mít omezení na n a m, ale ve všech případech bude vstupní funkce
nabývat takové podoby.
Když říkáme, že
výpočet provádí dotaz, myslíme tím, že funkce f je vyhodnocena jednou,
to jest výpočtem je vybrán nějaký řetězec x délky N a řetězec f(x) je
pak zpřístupněn výpočtu
oraclem nebo černou skříňkou. A konečně, velmi jednoduchý způsob, jakým budeme měřit výpočetní náklady
dotazovacího algoritmu, je počítat, kolik dotazů vyžaduje.
Ačkoli je pravda, že
nás skutečně nejvíce zajímá, jak dlouho trvají výpočty, při studiu dotazovacího modelu
obecně zjednodušujeme
a prostě počítáme dotazy, a to budeme dělat v této lekci.
Podívejme se nyní na
několik příkladů dotazovacích problémů, tedy výpočetních
problémů v dotazovacím modelu,
a zde jen popíšu
samotné problémy a v tuto chvíli neřeknu nic
o tom, jak je řešit.
Prvním problémem je problém OR.
V tomto případě je vstupem funkce
z n bitů na pouhý 1 bit, takže m se rovná 1 pro tento problém,
a požadovaný výstup
problému je buď 1 nebo 0.
Pokud existuje nějaký n-bitový řetězec x, pro který f(x) se rovná 1, pak správná odpověď je 1,
a jinak, pokud f(x) je
vždy 0 pro každý řetězec x, pak správná odpověď je 0.
Pokud si tedy funkci f představíme jako poskytující
náhodný přístup ke dvěma na n bitům, jednomu pro každý n-bitový řetězec x,
pak to, na co se ptáme,
je OR těchto bitů, a proto se tomu říká problém OR.
Dalším příkladem je problém parity, který je podobný problému OR, jenže žádá o paritu,
jinými slovy exkluzivní OR všech jednobitrových
výstupních hodnot funkce.
Jiný způsob, jak to říci, je,
že správná odpověď je 0, pokud je počet n-bitových řetězců x, pro které f(x) se rovná 1, sudý,
a správná odpověď je
1, pokud je toto číslo liché.
Příkladem problému, kde m není nutně rovno 1, je problém minima.
Zde funkce f nabývá obvyklé podoby a neexistují žádná omezení na n a m,
a správná odpověď je jakákoli výstupní hodnota
funkce, která přichází jako první v lexikografickém
nebo slovníkovém uspořádání
binárních řetězců. Nebo, pokud chceš
přemýšlet o řetězcích délky m jako o reprezentaci nezáporných
celých čísel v binárním zápisu,
pak správnou odpovědí
je nejmenší možná nebo minimální hodnota, která
z této funkce vychází.
WEBVTT
Někdy také uvažujeme dotazovací problémy, kde máme příslib
o vstupní funkci, jinými slovy nějaký druh záruky,
a nestaráme se o funkce, které tento příslib nesplňují.
Funkce, které příslib nesplňují, se považují za vstupy „nezáleží na nich".
A za to, co se stane na těchto vstupech, nejsme zodpovědní.
Zde je příklad dotazovacího problému s příslibem zvaného jedinečné hledání.
Souvisí s problémem OR, ale je jiný.
Vstupní funkce má stejnou
podobu jako pro problém OR, tedy přiřazuje
n-bitové řetězce bitům.
Tentokrát je nám slíbeno,
že existuje právě jeden řetězec Z, který způsobuje, že f vyhodnotí na 1,
přičemž f(x) se rovná 0
pro každý řetězec x kromě z, a správný výstup
je tento jedinečný řetězec z.
Samozřejmě existují
volby funkce f, které tuto podmínku nesplňují, ale na algoritmy pro tento problém nejsou kladeny žádné požadavky
v případě, že jim jsou takové
funkce dány jako vstup.
Zajímají nás pouze funkce, které příslib splňují.
Nyní, všechny čtyři
problémy, které jsem právě zmínil, jsou poměrně přirozené problémy, což znamená, že je snadné je vysvětlit,
a je snadné si představit situace, ve kterých by mohla vzniknout potřeba je řešit, ale některé dotazovací problémy
takové vůbec nejsou.
Ve skutečnosti někdy uvažujeme vysoce
uměle zkonstruované dotazovací problémy, kde je těžké si představit, že by je kdokoli kdy
skutečně chtěl řešit.
Simonův problém, který
uvidíme později v lekci, do této kategorie trochu patří, ale existují i jiné
které jsou v jistém smyslu mnohem horší, ale přesto jsou ve skutečnosti pro studium dotazovacího modelu docela důležité.
Tyto problémy nestudujeme proto, že bychom nutně chtěli
je řešit v praxi.
Způsob, jak o tom přemýšlet, je, že hledáme
extrémy různých druhů,
konkrétně při práci v rámci
této Petriho misky modelu je přirozeným způsobem zkoumání
kvantových algoritmických myšlenek
formulovat vysoce uměle zkonstruované problémy, kde nejlépe využijeme
sílu kvantových počítačů.
A to skutečně může
velmi osvětlit, jak by kvantové počítače
mohly být potenciálně užitečné v praktičtějších prostředích.
Pojem dotazu můžeme
formalizovat různými způsoby v závislosti na tom, s jakým výpočetním
modelem pracujeme.
Například v modelu Turingova
stroje, o kterém jsme nemluvili a do nějž v této sérii nevejdeme,
existuje určitý způsob
formalizace pojmu dotazu, který dává smysl pro tento model.
Pro modely circuit definujeme speciální typy
gate nazývané dotazovací gate, a takto jsou dotazy
formálně reprezentovány.
Pro Booleovské circuit existuje velmi jednoduchý způsob, jak to udělat, a to jednoduše si představit,
že máme dotazovací gate,
které přímo vyhodnocují vstupní funkci, jak vidíš zde na obrazovce.
Myšlenka je, že tyto dotazovací gate můžeme
použít k sestavení circuit, které řeší jakýkoli
problém, na nějž se zaměřujeme,
a aby fungovaly správně, circuit musí dávat správnou odpověď pro jakoukoli vstupní funkci f,
za předpokladu, že splňuje příslib v případě problému s příslibem.
Zde je jednoduchý příklad
Booleovského circuit, který řeší problém parity, když n se rovná 1,
takže vstupní funkce f je
v tomto případě z 1 bitu na 1 bit.
Tento circuit vyhodnocuje funkci
f na vstupech 0 a 1 pomocí těchto dvou dotazovacích gate.
Poté zapojí dvě výstupní hodnoty, které
dostane z dotazovacích gate, do Booleovského circuit z lekce tři, který počítá XOR,
což je totéž co parita.
Jen pro upřesnění, tyto dvě
vstupní hodnoty tady nejsou vstupy do problému,
čímž myslím problém parity,
když pracujeme s dotazovacím modelem, vstupem do problému
je funkce f, a tyto
dva vstupy do circuit
si představ jako napevno zakódované
hodnoty, které se nikdy nemění, jsou v podstatě součástí algoritmu.
Chceme vypočítat XOR f(0) a f(1), takže tyto
dva vodiče inicializujeme tímto způsobem,
aby to fungovalo. Použili jsme zde dva dotazovací gate,
tento a tento,
takže algoritmus reprezentovaný
tímto Booleovským circuit provádí dva dotazy, a pokud na chvíli uvažujeme o problému parity
pro funkce z jednoho bitu na jeden bit, vidíme, že je absolutně nezbytné pro jakýkoli Booleovský circuit
řešící tento problém,
aby provedl alespoň dva dotazy.
Pokud provedete pouze jeden dotaz, takže znáte pouze jednu
výstupní hodnotu funkce f a ne druhou, vlastně nemáš vůbec žádné informace
o paritě, protože druhá výstupní hodnota
by stejně dobře mohla být 0 nebo 1, což vede k oběma
možným řešením
problému. Takže z hlediska počtu
dotazů, které provádí, je tento Booleovský circuit tak dobrý, jak jen to jde
pro problém parity
když n se rovná 1.
WEBVTT
Je ještě jeden bod o dotazovacích gate, který stojí za zmínku, než se posuneme dále, a to, že při navrhování a analýze dotazovacích algoritmů
se vůbec nestaráme o to, jak
jsou dotazovací gate implementovány.
Předpokládá se, že
tyto dotazovací gate jsou nám dány, a obtížnost jejich sestavení
není naším problémem.
Dotazovací gate samotné si
můžeš představit jako vstup, pokud chceš, a není naším úkolem vytvářet vstup, snažíme se pouze
vyřešit konkrétní problém
daný vstupem. Samozřejmě, když f je funkce
z jednoho bitu na jeden bit, existují pouze čtyři možné volby,
a bylo by dost snadné
implementovat kteroukoli z nich, ale obecně pro funkce
s mnoha vstupními bity
by mohlo být velmi obtížné implementovat dotazovací gate
pro tyto funkce.
Jen pro upřesnění, to není
řečeno proto, že otázka implementace dotazovacích gate není důležitá, ale spíše proto, že není považována
za součást nákladů
dotazovacího algoritmu.
To je v souladu s myšlenkou, že to skutečně není
o praktickém výpočtu nebo skutečném sestavování circuit jako takovém,
ale o práci v rámci
teoretického rámce, který nám říká zajímavé
věci o výpočtu.
Více k tomu řekneme, až přejdeme z tohoto modelu na standardnější model výpočtu, a to je hlavně náplní příští lekce,
Lekce 6.
Nyní obraťme pozornost
na kvantové circuit.
Pro kvantové circuit změníme
definici dotazovacích gate tak, aby byly unitární.
Chceme být schopni provádět
dotazy v rámci kvantových circuit a aby operovaly
lineárně na kvantových stavech,
abychom mohli efektivně
provádět dotazy v superpozici.
Může se zdát, jako bychom přesunuli
branky, abychom tak řekli, změnou toho, co myslíme dotazem, ve srovnání s tím, co jsme právě
viděli pro Booleovské circuit,
ale existuje pro to odůvodnění, které probereme podrobněji v příští lekci.
Pro tuto chvíli je to jen definice.
Konkrétně, definice
je následující: pro jakoukoli funkci f stejné podoby jako předtím,
tedy takovou, která přiřazuje n-bitové
řetězce na m-bitové řetězce, dotazovací gate Uf operuje na n + m qubit
a je definována
akcí popsanou zde na standardních bázových stavech.
Za chvíli uvidíme obrázek
reprezentující tuto definici, ale nejprve objasním notaci,
která se zde používá,
a to kdykoli používáme
symbol pro XOR jako operaci mezi dvěma
řetězci stejné délky,
myslíme tím
bitový exkluzivní OR, a zde vidíš příklad.
V definici máme, že y i f(x) jsou
řetězce délky m, takže tento řetězec tady
reprezentuje řetězec, který dostaneme
XORováním těchto dvou řetězců
dohromady, bit po bitu, a zde je diagram
vysvětlující, jak tyto gate fungují.
Horních n qubit odpovídá
argumentu funkce.
A když začínají
ve standardním bázovém stavu, ket x v tomto diagramu, tento standardní bázový stav
prochází nezměněn
a je odražen jako součást výstupu.
Spodních m qubit odpovídá výstupu
funkce f, a když začínají
v jakémkoli standardním bázovém stavu,
ket y v tomto diagramu, dojde k tomu, že výstup funkce f(x) je XORován na řetězec y.
Toto je to, co se děje pro
standardní bázové stavy, a pokud chceme vědět,
co se děje obecně pro jiné kvantové stavy, používáme linearitu, jak vždy.
Důvodem definování dotazovacích gate tímto způsobem, kde odrážíme vstup a používáme bitový XOR pro výstup,
je, že tyto gate jsou vždy unitární pro jakoukoli volbu funkce f.
Jedná se o
deterministickou operaci.
A kdybychom ji vyjádřili jako matici pro jakoukoli volbu funkce F, dostali bychom permutační matici,
tedy takovou s jediným jedničkou v každém řádku a v každém sloupci, a všemi ostatními prvky rovnými 0.
A permutační matice
jsou vždy unitární.
Ve skutečnosti pro tuto operaci dostaneme, že operace
je svou vlastní inverzí, takže Uf dagger se rovná Uf.
Pokud s těmito gate chceme jen
vyhodnotit f(x) pro nějaký řetězec x, je to snadné,
stačí nastavit y jako
řetězec samých nul. Takže když vezmeme bitový XOR s y, dostaneme pouze f(x).
Zde mimochodem vidíš notaci, která se používá pro označení řetězce samých nul.
Vypadá jako 0 na mocninu M, ale to není, co znamená.
Znamená řetězec nul
délky rovné M.
Když mluvíme o
řetězcích na rozdíl od čísel, exponenty obvykle znamenají, že daný řetězec opakujeme
určitý počet krát,
takže toto je 0 opakované m krát.
WEBVTT
Je to jen pohodlný a přesný způsob popisu tohoto řetězce.
Opět, když pracujeme
s dotazovacím modelem, nestaráme se o to, jak
implementovat tyto dotazovací gate.
To je stejný problém,
jaký jsme měli s dotazovacími gate pro Booleovský circuit.
Není naším úkolem připravit vstup, vstup nám je dán ve
formě těchto dotazovacích gate.
Nicméně upozorním, že pokud víme, jak
implementovat funkci f pomocí Booleovského circuit, pak je možné
přeložit tuto implementaci
poměrně přímo na kvantovou
implementaci circuit Uf, a přesně to, jak to funguje, uvidíme v příští lekci.
Jen na okraj, je docela přímočaré vytvořit Booleovský circuit
fungující takto, pomocí jediného klasického
dotazovacího gate pro funkci f,
ale to se velmi liší od toho mít kvantovou
implementaci circuit tohoto unitárního gate.
Nicméně pointa je, že
pro klasické dotazovací algoritmy, mít dotazovací gate fungující takto, je ve skutečnosti ekvivalentní
tomu mít obyčejný
klasický dotazovací gate pro f, v tom smyslu, že jeden z nich lze implementovat pomocí druhého.
V této části lekce probereme Deutschův algoritmus, který je velmi jednoduchým
kvantovým dotazovacím algoritmem, ale je skutečně klenotem.
Tento algoritmus pochází z článku z roku 1985, který napsal David Deutsch, byl jedním z úplně prvních lidí pracujících na teoretických
základech kvantových výpočtů.
Algoritmus sám představuje velmi malou část
Deutschova článku z roku 1985, a ve skutečnosti
algoritmus, který nyní
nazýváme Deutschův algoritmus, je vlastně vylepšená verze algoritmu, který Deutsch popsal.
Poskytuje velmi skromný příklad toho, jak kvantové počítače mohou
nabídnout výpočetní výhody, ale někde začít musíš,
a byl to skutečně důležitý impuls, který vše nastartoval.
Deutschův algoritmus řeší dotazovací problém, který se v kontextu kvantových výpočtů často nazývá Deutschův problém,
ale ve skutečnosti je to nic jiného
než problém parity pro funkce z jednoho bitu na jeden bit, o kterém jsme již mluvili.
Jak jsme již viděli, existují čtyři funkce
z jednoho bitu na jeden bit, a jsou zde popsány tabulkami hodnot.
První a poslední z těchto
funkcí jsou konstantní, zatímco střední dvě jsou vyvážené v tom smyslu, že dvě
možné výstupní hodnoty
se vyskytují stejně často.
Pro dvě konstantní funkce
vidíme, že parita, jinými slovy exkluzivní OR dvou výstupů je 0,
a pro dvě vyvážené funkce je parita výstupů 1.
Ekvivalentní způsob
popisu problému parity v tomto konkrétním případě, kdy funkce f přijímá
jediný bit jako vstup,
jinými slovy Deutschův problém, je takový, jak vidíš zde.
Vstupem je funkce f
z jednoho bitu na jeden bit, a výstupem je 0, pokud je f konstantní,
a 1, pokud je f vyvážená.
Jak jsem již naznačil, každý klasický dotazovací algoritmus
řešící tento problém musí provést alespoň dva dotazy na f.
Pokud se dozvíš pouze jednu ze
dvou výstupních hodnot f, stále nemáš vůbec žádné informace o paritě dvou výstupů.
A to, mimochodem, platí
i pro klasické algoritmy využívající náhodnost.
Náhodnost může být někdy velmi užitečná pro řešení dotazovacích problémů, a uvidíme příklad
o něco později v lekci,
ale zde náhodnost nepomáhá.
Takže náš dřívější algoritmus je optimální mezi klasickými dotazovacími algoritmy
pro Deutschův problém.
Nyní se podíváme
na Deutschův algoritmus, což je kvantový dotazovací algoritmus, který řeší Deutschův
problém pomocí jediného dotazu.
A zde je algoritmus
popsán jako kvantový circuit.
Máme dva qubit
inicializované jak vidíš zde, s horním inicializovaným na ket 0 a spodním inicializovaným na ket 1,
a brzy uvidíme, proč inicializujeme tyto qubit právě takto.
Provedeme Hadamard
gate na dvou qubit, vložíme je do dotazovacího gate, provedeme další Hadamard
gate na horním qubit,
a poté ho změříme. A tvrzení je, že
výsledek měření nám dává s jistotou
správnou odpověď na problém.
Pojďme tedy analyzovat
circuit krok za krokem, abychom přesně viděli, jak funguje.
Stav dvou qubit po první vrstvě Hadamard gate je tenzorový součin
stavů minus a plus.
Hadamard nahoře přiřazuje
stav 0 stavu plus, a Hadamard dole přiřazuje stav 1 stavu minus.
Horní qubit je vpravo a spodní qubit je vlevo, takže toto je stav, který dostaneme.
Je velmi důležité, aby spodní qubit byl ve stavu minus, mimochodem, toto by nefungovalo, kdybychom
inicializovali spodní qubit
do stavu 0 místo stavu 1.
Rozvineme tento stav
napůl, jak vidíš zde.
Důvod pro to
není v tuto chvíli jasný, ale za chvíli to bude výhodné.
Dále přemýšlejme o
stavu dvou qubit po provedení dotazovacího gate.
Dotazovací gate
funguje tak, že vypočítá F na standardním bázovém
stavu horního qubit a XORuje hodnotu
na spodní qubit,
WEBVTT
a zde vidíme
výsledek toho.
Pro první člen je standardní bázový stav
horního qubit roven 0, takže f(0) je XORováno
na spodní qubit,
a to funguje díky linearitě. A podobně pro druhý člen, jenže standardní bázový stav
pro horní qubit je 1, takže XORujeme f(1) na spodní qubit.
A v tuto chvíli můžeme
tento výraz zjednodušit pozorováním vzorce,
který vidíš dole, který platí, když a je buď 0 nebo 1.
A můžeme to jednoduše ověřit pro tyto dvě hodnoty zvlášť.
Pokud a se rovná 0, pak
XOR s a nic nedělá, a záporná 1 na mocninu 0 je 1,
takže obě strany jsou si rovny. A pokud a se rovná 1, dostaneme ket 1 minus ket
0 při XOR,
což je záporná 1
krát ket 0 minus ket 1.
A pokud použijeme tento vzorec
k zjednodušení našeho stavu, kde bereme a rovné
f(0) vlevo a a rovné f(1) vpravo,
dostaneme výraz,
který vidíš právě zde.
Takže když porovnáme dva
vektory kvantového stavu π1 a π2, vidíme, že to, co gate Uf dělá,
je efektivně umístit
jednu ze dvou hodnot, f(0) nebo f(1), do
exponentu záporné 1,
jinými slovy
do fáze každého členu.
To je důvod pro
inicializaci spodního qubit na 1 a provedení Hadamard gate na něm k vytvoření stavu minus,
který to umožňuje.
Nazývá se to jev zpětného kopnutí fáze (phase kickback), a za chvíli se k němu vrátíme, abychom se na něj podívali z jiného úhlu.
Je docela důležitý a uvidíme ho
ještě několikrát v lekci, stejně jako v pozdějších lekcích.
Nyní můžeme zjednodušit vytažením
stavu minus zpět ven a dostat výraz,
který vidíš právě zde.
Mimochodem, je
trochu zajímavé si všimnout, že zde ve skutečnosti
není žádné provázání.
Oba tyto stavy jsou produktové stavy. Takže, ačkoli je provázání extrémně zajímavé,
v tomto konkrétním algoritmu
nehraje vůbec žádnou roli.
Trochu to uklidíme, abychom měli o něco více prostoru.
Co nyní můžeme udělat, je vytáhnout
faktor záporné 1 na mocninu f(0) ven
a dostat výraz stavu,
který vidíš právě zde.
Všimneš si, že tady máme exkluzivní OR f(0) a f(1) v exponentu záporné 1.
Mohli bychom očekávat, že to bude
f(1) minus f(0), protože vytahujeme faktor záporné 1 na mocninu f(0) ven,
ale dostaneme stejnou
hodnotu, pokud vezmeme XOR, protože to jsou bity, a jediné, na čem záleží, když máme celé číslo
v exponentu záporné 1,
je, zda je toto celé číslo sudé nebo liché.
Jiný způsob, jak vyjádřit tento
stav, je jako zde, kde uvažujeme pouze
dva možné případy pro XOR.
A to je pohodlný
způsob vyjádření stavu, jak uvažujeme o akci
posledního Hadamard gate spolu s měřením.
Když provedeme poslední
Hadamard gate na horním qubit, stav plus je
transformován do stavu 0
a stav minus je
transformován do stavu 1, což můžeme zapsat stručněji takto.
A konečně, když je
provedeno měření, výsledek, který dostaneme, je
tedy XOR f(0) a f(1),
což je hodnota, kterou hledáme, a takto Deutschův algoritmus funguje.
Je to poměrně jednoduché, a pokud se ptáme, co
to způsobuje, co nám umožňuje vypočítat
paritu dvou bitů
jediným dotazem místo dvěma, rozumná odpověď je,
že je to interference.
Efektivně
vypočítáváme f(0) a f(1) současně, protože nejprve provedeme
Hadamard gate
na horním qubit, abychom dali vstup do f do
superpozice 0 a 1.
A pomocí zpětného kopnutí fáze spolu s posledním Hadamard gate v podstatě vytváříme
konstruktivní interferenci
pro správnou odpověď a destruktivní interferenci
pro špatnou odpověď.
Takže špatnou odpověď nevidíme, vidíme pouze správnou odpověď.
Nyní řeknu o fenoménu zpětného kopnutí fáze trochu více, jen abychom se na něj podívali
z trochu jiného úhlu.
Nejprve si všimněme
tohoto velmi jednoduchého vzorce, kde b a c jsou libovolné binární hodnoty.
Zkráceně, XORování bitu b hodnotou 1 je totéž jako provedení gate NOT nebo operace x na b,
a samozřejmě XORování
bitu b hodnotou 0 s ním nic neudělá, což je totéž jako provedení
operace identity na něm.
A operaci identity můžeme vyjádřit jako x na mocninu 0.
Takže pokud provedeme gate Uf na dvou qubit ve standardním bázovém
stavu ket b tenzor ket a,
dostaneme tento výsledek, jen z definice gate Uf.
WEBVTT
a pomocí vzorce můžeme alternativně zapsat tento stav, jak vidíš právě zde.
Tento vzorec platí pro všechny volby b, takže díky linearitě platí
pro libovolný stav SI
místo ket b.
A konkrétně, pokud chceme, můžeme zvolit SI jako stav minus.
A zde je klíč k tomu, proč dochází k fenoménu zpětného kopnutí fáze.
Je to proto, že operace x
aplikovaná na stav minus nám dává zápornou 1 krát stav minus.
Matematicky říkáme, že stav minus
je vlastní vektor operace x, s vlastní hodnotou rovnou záporné 1.
Vlastní vektory a vlastní hodnoty
jsou kriticky důležité v lineární algebře stejně
jako v kvantové informaci, a budeme o nich mít
co říci
jak série pokračuje.
Ale prozatím vše, co potřebujeme,
je tento jednoduchý vzorec.
A jeho pomocí můžeme
zjednodušit náš vektor stavu.
A toto je v podstatě fenomén zpětného kopnutí fáze zapsaný jako vzorec.
Funguje proto, že stav minus
je vlastní vektor operace NOT s
vlastní hodnotou záporná jedna.
Toto zobecníme
poměrně zásadním způsobem v Lekci 7, kdy přejdeme na proceduru odhadování fáze, která je tím, co pohání
Shorův algoritmus faktorizace.
Tento vzorec vidíme v praxi v analýze Deutschova
algoritmu takto.
Před dotazovacím gate je náš stav tenzorový součin stavů minus a plus.
Poté aplikujeme dotazovací gate a rozvinutí stavu plus
nám dává tento stav.
Nyní aplikujeme vzorec zpětného kopnutí fáze a dostaneme tento výraz, a poté analýza
pokračuje jako předtím.
Je to stejné jako předtím, ale zde se zaměřujeme na zpětné kopnutí fáze, abychom ho dokázali rozpoznat
a byli na něj připraveni,
až se znovu objeví.
Dále přejdeme na
algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa, který je rozšířením
Deutschova algoritmu a ve skutečnosti řeší několik
různých dotazovacích problémů.
Výhoda, kterou
Deutschův algoritmus poskytuje oproti klasickým algoritmům,
je poměrně skromná: jeden dotaz oproti dvěma.
Algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa tuto výhodu poněkud zvyšuje, a vysvětlím, co tím myslím,
až se tam dostaneme.
Algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa lze vnímat jako přirozený a přímý způsob rozšíření Deutschova algoritmu
z funkcí z jednoho bitu na jeden bit na funkce z n bitů na jeden bit, jinými slovy funkce této podoby.
Jako kvantový circuit vypadá algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa
takto, a budu to nazývat circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
jen abych vytvořil malý
rozdíl mezi tímto circuit a samotným algoritmem Deutsch-Jozsa, protože existuje také
krok klasického post-processingu.
Myšlenka je, že pokud spustíme
tento circuit a poté změříme, dostaneme nějaký n-bitový řetězec y
který nám říká něco
o funkci f.
V tuto chvíli jsem mimochodem ještě neřekl,
jaký dotazovací problém doufáme
vyřešit pomocí tohoto circuit, to přijde velmi brzy.
Ale pointa je, že
spuštěním tohoto circuit získáme nějaké informace o f, které nám potenciálně mohou pomoci
vyřešit dotazovací problémy,
kde je f vstupem. A jak jsem řekl před chvílí, tento circuit skutečně můžeme použít
k řešení několika
různých dotazovacích problémů.
Nejprve se podívejme
na dotazovací problém známý jako problém Deutsch-Jozsa, což je problém, který měl circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
původně řešit.
Problém Deutsch-Jozsa je zobecněním Deutschova problému, kde cílem je určit, zda je daná funkce
konstantní nebo vyvážená.
Všimni si, že toto není přirozený způsob zobecnění problému parity
na funkce této podoby.
Zde nepočítáme paritu, úkolem je vypsat 0, pokud
je funkce f konstantní,
a 1, pokud je funkce f vyvážená.
První věc, které je třeba si u tohoto problému všimnout, je, že když n, počet vstupních bitů
funkce f, je alespoň 2,
existují volby funkce, které nejsou ani konstantní, ani vyvážené.
Například, zde je
funkce z 2 bitů na 1 bit, která není ani konstantní, ani vyvážená.
Není konstantní, protože obě binární hodnoty
se mezi výstupy vyskytují, a není vyvážená,
protože dvě výstupní hodnoty
se vyskytují s různou frekvencí. 0 se vyskytuje třikrát
a 1 jen jednou.
Aby byla vyvážená,
výstupy 0 a 1 musí se vyskytovat přesně
stejně často.
Skutečnost, že existují funkce, které nejsou ani konstantní, ani vyvážené, když n je alespoň 2, je v pořádku, jen budeme takové funkce považovat
za vstupy „nezáleží na nich". Jinými slovy, toto
je problém s příslibem.
A zde je přesné
vyjádření problému.
WEBVTT
Je nám slíbeno, že vstupní funkce f je buď konstantní nebo vyvážená, a cílem je zjistit,
která z nich to je.
A nejsme zodpovědní za to, co se stane, pokud vstup
nesplňuje příslib.
Algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa,
který tento problém řeší, spočívá nejprve ve spuštění circuit Deutsch-Jozsa a poté výpisu 0,
pokud řetězec, který
dostaneme z měření, je řetězec samých nul,
a jinak výpisu 1.
Jiný způsob, jak to říci, je, že vypíšeme OR
bitů, které změříme.
K analýze algoritmu Deutsch-Jozsa bude užitečné
nejprve věnovat chvíli zamyšlení nad Hadamard gate.
Operaci Hadamard samozřejmě
můžeme popsat jako matici, ale můžeme ji také popsat
z hlediska její akce
na standardní bázové stavy,
jak vidíš právě zde.
Tyto dvě rovnice lze
zkombinovat do jediné rovnice, která popisuje, jak operace
Hadamard funguje pro a jako jednu ze
dvou binárních hodnot,
a můžeme jít o trochu dál a vyjádřit, co
dostaneme, jako součet takto.
Pomocí tohoto vzorce můžeme přijít na vzorec, který popisuje, jak funguje vrstva
Hadamard gate, kde aplikujeme jeden Hadamard
gate na každý z n qubit.
Zde popisujeme tuto
akci na standardních bázových stavech.
A aby bylo jasno ohledně notace, když píšeme h tenzor n takto, kde část tenzor n je horním indexem,
myslíme tím n-násobný
tenzorový součin H se sebou, jinými slovy n kopií
h všechny tensored dohromady.
Tuto operaci aplikujeme
na standardní bázový stav, a zde dodržuji
konvenci, kterou používá Qiskit
k indexování binárních řetězců, protože je dobrý čas
tuto konvenci představit.
Takže x0 je bit, x1 je bit,
a tak dále s n bity celkem, a bity jsou seřazeny,
jak vidíš na obrazovce.
O tomto způsobu
indexování bitů můžeš přemýšlet jako odpovídajícím jejich váze, pokud vnímáme řetězce jako
reprezentaci celých čísel
v binárním zápisu, například.
Pokud aplikujeme Hadamard gate
na každý z těchto qubit, výsledek můžeme alternativně vyjádřit jako n-násobný tenzorový součin
Hadamard gate aplikovaného na každý qubit, a poté můžeme aplikovat náš vzorec na každý z tenzorových faktorů.
A zde používáme
jména y a záporná 1 dolů na y1 místo b ve vzorci,
takže to jsou binární hodnoty. A dbáme na to, abychom použili nové jméno pokaždé, když vzorec použijeme.
Pokud poté vše rozvineme pomocí multilinearity
tenzorových součinů, dostaneme výraz,
který vidíš právě zde.
A aby bylo jasno, n součtů je
zkombinováno do jediného součtu, ale stále sčítáme
přes všechny možné hodnoty
pro jednotlivé binární hodnoty.
Nyní věci uklidíme, abychom mohli jít o trochu dál.
A dalším krokem je
zavést novou operaci na řetězcích nazvanou binární skalární součin.
Toto je operace na binárních řetězcích stejné délky.
A binárním skalárním součinem dvou řetězců x a y
stejné délky je exkluzivní OR nebo parita
součinů jednotlivých bitů.
Také bychom mohli říci, že je to XOR logického AND jednotlivých bitů, protože AND je totéž jako součin
pro binární hodnoty. Ještě jiný způsob, jak to popsat,
je, že to je 1 nebo 0
v závislosti na tom, zda
je součet součinů jednotlivých bitů lichý nebo sudý.
Je to velmi podobné skalárnímu součinu, pokud uvažujeme o řetězcích
jako o vektorech binárních hodnot, ale kde počítáme modulo 2,
jinými slovy bereme zbytek po dělení 2.
Ve skutečnosti to ale není skalární součin, takže si zaslouží jiný název.
V daném případě můžeme použít binární skalární součin
k tomu, aby náš vzorec pro akci vrstvy Hadamard gate
na standardních bázových stavech byl stručnější, a tady ho máš.
Využíváme skutečnosti, že
protože tento součet se zde nachází v
exponentu záporné 1,
záleží pouze na tom,
zda je sudý nebo lichý, ale jinak je to v podstatě jen zkrácená
verze našeho vzorce.
Mimochodem, binární
skalární součin je symetrický v tom smyslu, že x tečka
y a y tečka x jsou si rovny,
takže pořadí můžeme volně měnit, kdykoli to je užitečné.
A nyní, když máme tento vzorec, bude poměrně snadné analyzovat
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa.
Začínáme s n qubit ve stavu 0 a spodním qubit ve stavu 1, a provádíme Hadamard
gate na všech z nich.
Toto je stav
n + 1 qubit, který dostaneme.
Zpracováváme spodní qubit
odděleně, protože to bude výhodné.
A opět uvidíme, jak se děje
fenomén zpětného kopnutí fáze.
WEBVTT
Tento výraz můžeme dostat
pomocí našeho vzorce, kde dosadíme řetězec samých nul za x a dosadíme x za y,
přičemž si uvědomíme, že binární skalární součin řetězce samých nul s jakýmkoli řetězcem je 0.
Ale můžeme to také odůvodnit přímo. Bereme tenzorový
součin n stavů plus, a toto je výsledek,
tenzor se stavem minus. Poté je aplikován gate UF, a zde dochází k fenoménu
zpětného kopnutí fáze.
Hodnota f(x) je
XORována na stav minus pro každé x v součtu.
Takže f(x) se kopne do fáze.
Nyní aplikujeme další
vrstvu Hadamard gate pouze na horních n qubit, a tentokrát skutečně
potřebujeme vzorec.
A když ho aplikujeme a provedeme jen trochu
zjednodušení, dostaneme tento stav právě zde.
To je tedy náš konečný stav těsně
před měřeními.
Stav vypadá trochu komplikovaně a je těžké ho zjednodušit, protože o funkci f toho moc nevíme.
Ale pamatuj, že vše, co
skutečně potřebujeme vědět, je, zda všechna měření dají výsledek 0,
protože to určuje, jaká je naše odpověď na problém.
Pokud vidíme, že každý
výsledek měření je 0, dospějeme k závěru, že funkce je konstantní.
A pokud je jakýkoli
výsledek měření 1, dospějeme k závěru, že funkce je vyvážená.
Pojďme tedy vypočítat pravděpodobnost, že z měření dostaneme řetězec samých nul.
A to se ukáže jako jediný výsledek, který je vlastně snadné vypočítat, protože binární skalární součin řetězce samých nul
s jakýmkoli řetězcem je nula. Pokud prozkoumáme náš vektor a
přemýšlíme o tom, co se stane, když y je řetězec samých nul,
dostaneme tento výraz
tady pro pravděpodobnost, že z měření dostaneme řetězec samých nul.
A s ohledem na dva možné případy, kde f je konstantní a f je vyvážená, vidíme, že pravděpodobnost
dostat řetězec samých nul je 1
v případě, že f je konstantní, a nula, když f je vyvážená.
Když f je konstantní, součet je buď 2 na n nebo záporné 2 na n, a vydělením dvěma na n
a vzatím absolutní
hodnoty na druhou dostaneme 1.
A když f je vyvážená, součet se rovná 0.
To proto, že kladnou 1 a zápornou 1 dostaneme stejný počet krát,
takže se navzájem vyruší.
To je vše. Algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa
řeší problém Deutsch-Jozsa pomocí jediného dotazu,
a bez chyby. Za předpokladu, že
všechny operace jsou provedeny dokonale, je správný pokaždé.
Jak se to tedy srovnává s tím,
co můžeme dělat klasicky?
Pokud trváme na
deterministickém algoritmu, který dostane správnou odpověď
pokaždé, pak v nejhorším případě
potřebujeme 2 na n minus 1 plus 1 dotazů, a to proto, že musíme dotázat funkci
na více než polovině jejích vstupů, abychom si byli jisti řešením.
I kdybychom dotazovali funkci na 2 na n minus 1
různých vstupních řetězcích, je možné, že uvidíme stejnou výstupní hodnotu
pokaždé, a to by mohlo být proto,
že funkce je konstantní, nebo to může být, že je ve skutečnosti vyvážená
a jen jsme měli neuvěřitelnou smůlu, že jsme pokaždé viděli stejnou výstupní hodnotu.
Takže to je obrovská výhoda
kvantových počítačů oproti klasickým: jediný dotaz oproti
exponenciálně mnoha dotazům.
Nicméně, pokud používáme
pravděpodobnostní dotazovací algoritmus a akceptujeme malou pravděpodobnost nesprávné odpovědi,
pak ve skutečnosti potřebujeme jen několik dotazů.
Konkrétně, pokud
náhodně zvolíme k řetězců a vyhodnotíme funkci
na těchto náhodných řetězcích,
pak jsme poměrně pravděpodobně schopni zjistit správnou odpověď.
Konkrétně odpovídáme 0 nebo konstantní, když pokaždé dostaneme stejnou hodnotu funkce, a 1 nebo vyvážená
kdykoli vidíme dvě
různé hodnoty funkce.
Pokud to uděláme, vždy budeme mít pravdu, když
funkce je konstantní, protože samozřejmě pokaždé uvidíme stejnou
výstupní hodnotu.
A pokud je f vyvážená, je velmi pravděpodobné, že uvidíme
dvě různé výstupní hodnoty.
Šance, že neuvidíme
obě výstupní hodnoty v tomto případě, je stejná jako šance, že hodíme mincí k krát
a pokaždé dostaneme
stejný výsledek.
Takže například, pokud nastavíme
k rovno 11, pravděpodobnost, že dostaneme špatnou odpověď, je menší než desetina procenta.
Takže zejména když vezmeme v úvahu skutečnost, že kvantové počítače nikdy nebudou v realitě dokonalé, nedostaneme tady
tak velkou výhodu,
ale děláme pokroky a máme kvantifikovatelnou výhodu kvantových oproti klasickým, která přesahuje Deutschův algoritmus.
Také můžeme použít circuit Deutsch-Jozsa k řešení jiného dotazovacího problému známého jako problém Bernstein-Vazirani.
Zde je vyjádření tohoto problému. Vstupem je funkce
z n bitů na 1 bit, stejně jako u problému Deutsch-Jozsa,
WEBVTT
a opět je to problém s příslibem.
Tentokrát příslib spočívá v tom, že existuje nějaký n-bitový řetězec s, pro který funkce f
funguje, jak vidíš právě zde,
kde výstup je dán
binárním skalárním součinem vstupu s tímto řetězcem s,
a cílem je jednoduše
najít řetězec s. Takže si můžeme představit, že
řetězec s je v jistém smyslu skrytý,
ale můžeme se o něm dozvědět
dotazováním se na f, a naším cílem je najít
tento skrytý řetězec.
Jen pro upřesnění, většina funkcí
tento příslib nesplní, ale jako obvykle se zajímáme pouze o
vstupní funkce, které ho splňují.
Ukáže se, že circuit Deutsch-Jozsa tento problém
ve skutečnosti řeší rovnou z krabice.
Pokud ho spustíme pro
funkci, jako je ta tady, která splňuje
příslib pro nějaký řetězec s, měření odhalí řetězec s
bez jakéhokoli post-processingu.
Podívejme se, jak to funguje.
Již jsme analyzovali
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa, takže se vlastně můžeme rovnou přeskočit na konec.
Zde je výraz, který jsme
měli dříve pro stav těsně před měřeními, a tento výraz byl
platný pro jakoukoli funkci f.
A nyní, pokud dosadíme
to, co nám je slíbeno o funkci f, a zjednodušíme,
dostaneme stav minus
pro spodní qubit tenzor s ket s pro horních n qubit.
A tak dostaneme s při měření.
Zjednodušení, která jsem zde ukázal, vyžadují nějakou práci, a v tomto videu to neprojdu,
ale v textovém obsahu pro tuto sérii jsou o tom podrobnější informace, které najdeš na odkazu v popisu videa,
nebo to zkus sám
pro procvičení.
Takže jsme zjistili, že
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa řeší problém Bernstein-Vazirani
pomocí jediného dotazu.
Není příliš těžké ukázat,
že jakýkoli klasický algoritmus, ať deterministický
nebo pravděpodobnostní, potřebuje alespoň n dotazů
k řešení problému Bernstein-Vazirani z prostého důvodu, že potřebujeme n bitů
informace pro nalezení s,
a každý dotaz nám dá nejvýše
1 bit informace.
Takže dostáváme další výhodu kvantových oproti klasickým
dotazovacím algoritmům: jeden dotaz pro kvantové algoritmy,
n dotazů pro klasické algoritmy.
Stojí za to věnovat chvíli tomu, abychom promluvili o
názvosloví, které se v kontextu tohoto problému používá, a trochu o historii.
Lidé někdy označují algoritmus, který jsem právě popsal, jako algoritmus Bernstein-Vazirani, ale je to vlastně jen
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa,
a to je něco, co bylo
ve skutečnosti velmi jasně uvedeno v práci Bernsteina a Vazirani.
Takže je trochu zvláštní, že se tomu říká algoritmus Bernstein-Vazirani, protože je to v podstatě totéž co algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa
bez post-processingu. Bernstein a Vazirani však
šli o krok dále.
Definovali rekurzivní
verzi tohoto problému, kde v podstatě
musíš řešit instance problému Bernstein-Vazirani
pro odemknutí nových instancí problému, které jsou uspořádány v
komplikovaném stromovém vzoru.
Je to vysoce uměle zkonstruovaný problém, ale pointa je, že
definováním problému tímto způsobem mohli efektivně roztáhnout
separaci jedna versus n dotazů mezi kvantovými a klasickými.
A to, co získali, je
vůbec první známý příklad tzv. super-polynomiální výhody kvantových oproti pravděpodobnostním algoritmům.
Tato rekurzivní verze problému
Bernstein-Vazirani se o hodně později ukázala být velmi zajímavá i v teorii výpočetní složitosti z různých důvodů.
Každopádně, pointa je, že
Bernstein a Vazirani si jistě zaslouží uznání za jejich důležité příspěvky,
ale skutečně nedává
smysl to označovat jako algoritmus Bernstein-Vazirani, je to v podstatě jen
algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa.
V poslední části lekce se podíváme na jeden
další kvantový dotazovací algoritmus, Simonův algoritmus.
Uvidíš jasnou podobnost
mezi tímto algoritmem a algoritmem Deutsch-Jozsa, ale je jiný, a co je důležitější,
odhaluje mnohem silnější výhodu kvantových oproti klasickým
dotazovacím algoritmům.
Konkrétně nám dává
prokazatelnou exponenciální výhodu kvantových oproti klasickým algoritmům, i těm pravděpodobnostním.
Problém, který řeší, je trochu umělý a je těžké si představit situaci, ve které by řešení tohoto
problému bylo užitečné,
ale přímo inspiroval
Petera Shora k objevení kvantového algoritmu
pro faktorizaci celých čísel,
a to velmi silně podporuje
tuto myšlenku dotazovacího modelu jako Petriho misky, v níž mohou být rozvíjeny kvantové algoritmické
myšlenky.
Začněme dotazovacím problémem, který Simonův algoritmus řeší, který, jak možná tušíš,
se nazývá Simonův problém.
Zde je vyjádření problému a budeme ho muset rozbalit, abychom pochopili, o čem vlastně je.
První věc, které je třeba
si všimnout, je, že tentokrát vstupní funkce f přiřazuje n-bitové
řetězce na m-bitové řetězce,
kde m je nějaké kladné celé číslo, které obecně není rovno jedné.
WEBVTT
Je to problém s příslibem. A stejně jako u problému Bernstein-Vazirani příslib zahrnuje nějaký řetězec s, který si můžeme představit jako skrytý řetězec,
a také stejně jako u
problému Bernstein-Vazirani je cílem vypsat
tento skrytý řetězec s.
Příslib je však tentokrát
složitější, takže si ho pojďme rozebrat a
pochopit, co říká.
Začněme tím, že ho přečteme. Říká, že existuje řetězec s délky rovné n
takový, že určitá podmínka „právě tehdy, když" platí pro všechny volby n-bitových řetězců x a y.
Konkrétně musí
platit, že f(x) se rovná f(y) právě tehdy a jen tehdy, když nastane jedna ze
dvou možností.
První možností je, že x se rovná y, a druhou možností je, že když vezmeme
bitový exkluzivní OR z x
a skrytého řetězce s, dostaneme y.
Ukáže se, že je to
poměrně přísný příslib v tom smyslu, že většina
funkcí ho nesplní.
Tuto podmínku splňují pouze
velmi speciální funkce.
Abychom lépe pochopili tento příslib, a tedy i samotný problém, uvažujeme dva hlavní případy.
Prvním případem je, že s
je řetězec samých nul.
V tomto případě můžeme zjednodušit podmínku „právě tehdy, když" v příslibu, protože bitový
exkluzivní OR jakéhokoli řetězce x
s řetězcem samých nul
je jednoduše řetězec x.
Takže podmínka se zjednodušuje
na f(x) se rovná f(y) právě tehdy a jen tehdy, když x se rovná y.
A to je jen jiný způsob, jak říci, že f je prostá funkce.
Jinými slovy, řetězec f(x) musí být jedinečný
pro každý možný řetězec x.
Takže pokud je f prostá funkce, pak je příslib skutečně splněn, konkrétně pro s rovné
řetězci samých nul,
a v tomto případě je to
správný výstup.
Druhým případem je, že s
není řetězec samých nul, a z toho plyne, že funkce f musí být dva ku jedné.
Takže pro každý vstupní řetězec x existuje právě jeden další řetězec, na který f přiřadí stejný
řetězec, na který přiřadí x,
a navíc ten druhý řetězec
musí být řetězec, který dostaneme vzatím bitového
exkluzivního OR z x se s.
Jiný způsob, jak to říci,
je, že každý n-bitový řetězec x má partnera, a ten partner je řetězec, který dostaneme
vzatím bitového exkluzivního OR se s.
Jakékoli dva partneři musí dávat
stejný výstupní řetězec, když je vložíme do f, a žádné jiné řetězce nesmí dávat
stejný výstupní řetězec.
Takže tyto jsou nutně různé řetězce, které partneři produkují.
Zde je příklad takové funkce popsané tabulkou hodnot.
Takže toto je funkce
z 3 bitů na 5 bitů.
Pokud se na tuto tabulku
hodnot chvíli zadíváme, zjistíme, že příslib je
splněn pro řetězec 011.
000 a 011 jsou partneři. XORováním kteréhokoli z nich
hodnotou s dostaneme druhý,
a mají stejnou výstupní hodnotu, což je v tomto konkrétním případě 10011, a žádné jiné řetězce tento výstupní řetězec neprodukují.
001 a 010 jsou partneři, protože XORováním buď
jednoho hodnotou s dostaneme druhý, a produkují stejnou výstupní hodnotu,
která opět není produkována
žádným jiným řetězcem.
A situace je
podobná pro 100 a 111, stejně jako 101 a 110.
Takže pokud vstupem do
problému je tato funkce, správnou odpovědí je řetězec 011.
Jak jsem řekl dříve, většina funkcí tento příslib nesplňuje, je to velmi specifická podmínka.
Je třeba také poznamenat, že
pokud je příslib splněn, může být splněn pouze pro jeden řetězec s.
Takže na tento problém existuje vždy
pouze jedna správná odpověď.
To je tedy Simonův problém. Jak jsem řekl, je těžké si představit praktickou situaci, ve které bys tento problém chtěl řešit,
ale to není podstata. Podstata je pokusit se zjistit, v čem jsou kvantové počítače dobré, a ukáže se, že jsou daleko lepší
než klasické algoritmy při
řešení tohoto konkrétního problému.
Nyní se podívejme
na Simonův algoritmus, který řeší Simonův problém.
Algoritmus spočívá v
opakovaném spouštění kvantového circuit, který vidíš zde, následovaném klasickým
krokem post-processingu,
a přesněji upřesníme, co „opakovaně"
znamená, o něco později.
Circuit vypadá velmi podobně
jako circuit Deutsch-Jozsa, tentokrát protože funkce
f přiřazuje n bitů na m bitů,
je dotazovací gate jiný. Místo pouhého jednoho
qubit dole, máme nyní m qubit dole
a n nahoře jako předtím.
Klíčový rozdíl je, že dole
nenastavujeme stav minus ani více stavů minus.
Tyto spodní qubit jsou všechny
inicializovány do stavu 0 a tyto stavy přicházejí přímo
do dotazovacího gate.
WEBVTT
Takže v tomto algoritmu nebude žádné zpětné kopnutí fáze, takto tento prostě nefunguje.
Kromě rozdílů, které jsem
právě zmínil, to ale vypadá velmi podobně jako
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa.
Aplikujeme vrstvu Hadamard gate, poté aplikujeme dotazovací gate jednou, a poté aplikujeme další
vrstvu Hadamard gate
následovanou standardními bázovými měřeními horních n qubit.
Myšlenka je, že pokaždé, když spustíme tento circuit a změříme, dostaneme nějaký řetězec y, který nám říká něco
o skrytém řetězci s
v Simonově problému. A opakovaným spouštěním circuit
nezávisle shromáždíme dostatečné
statistické důkazy o s,
abychom mohli zjistit, co to je s vysokou spolehlivostí.
Pojďme nyní analyzovat kvantový
circuit pro Simonův algoritmus, abychom viděli, co dělá.
Stav po první
vrstvě Hadamard gate vypadá takto, podobně jako to, co jsme měli pro
algoritmus Deutsch-Jozsa.
Tentokrát jsou ale spodní m qubit všechny ve stavu 0
a ne ve stavech minus.
Po provedení dotazovacího gate vidíme, že hodnota f(x) byla zapsána na
spodní nebo nejlevější m qubit,
protože f(x) bylo XORováno na řetězec samých nul.
Takže opět, v tomto algoritmu nedochází k žádnému zpětnému kopnutí fáze.
Poté provedeme druhou
vrstvu Hadamard gate.
A pomocí stejného vzorce jako předtím pro akci
vrstvy Hadamard gate na standardní bázový
stav, ket x v tomto případě,
jak to bylo v původním vzorci, dostaneme tento stav právě zde, kde akce Hadamard gate
je zřejmější. Pokud ale chceme, můžeme také zapsat stav
v kompaktnější podobě, jak máme právě zde.
V tuto chvíli změříme horních n qubit a dostaneme nějaký n-bitový řetězec y, a potřebujeme jen zjistit, jaké jsou pravděpodobnosti
pro různé řetězce. A to nám pomůže pochopit,
jaké informace dostaneme z tohoto řetězce y o řetězci s,
který je skrytý uvnitř funkce f.
Pro toto budeme potřebovat
více prostoru, a diagram circuit již nepotřebujeme, takže se ho zbavme a dejme si
více prostoru pro analýzu.
Zde je stav těsně
před měřeními, což jsou standardní bázová měření horních nebo nejpravějších n qubit.
Takže měření
odpovídá druhému ketu.
Označme p(y) pravděpodobnost, že měření nám dají řetězec y pro každé možné y.
A pokud dodržíme pravidla z Lekce 2, dostaneme, že každá z těchto pravděpodobností je druhá mocnina Euklidovské normy vektoru, který je tensored
na standardní bázový stav,
odpovídající proč v
našem vektoru kvantového stavu.
To nám dává tento výraz právě zde.
Abychom lépe zvládli
tyto pravděpodobnosti, budeme potřebovat použít určitou notaci, a možná tuto notaci
již znáš,
protože je poměrně běžná v matematice.
Za prvé, když se odkazujeme na
obor hodnot funkce f, myslíme tím jednoduše množinu všech řetězců, které mohou z této funkce vyjít.
Takže je to množina všech f(x) pro všechny možné
volby vstupního řetězce x.
Za druhé, budeme používat tuto notaci, kterou vidíš právě zde, označující množinu všech vstupních řetězců x,
na které f přiřadí daný řetězec z, pro jakoukoli volbu
z, kterou chceme uvažovat.
Trochu to připomíná
inverzi funkce f, ale není to skutečně inverzní funkce, protože f není nutně invertibilní.
Také vidíme, že
na levé straně máme jako argument množinu, a v tomto případě je to množina obsahující
jen jeden řetězec z,
a to je nápověda, kterou potřebujeme k rozpoznání toho, že nemluvíme o
inverzní funkci f, toto se nazývá vzor.
Vzor lze
definovat obecněji pro jakoukoli množinu danou jako argument, ne jen množinu obsahující
jeden prvek,
ale toto vše, co budeme potřebovat. Není to nejlepší
notace na světě, protože je snadné ji zaměnit s inverzní funkcí,
ale je dostatečně jasná
a je široce používána, takže s ní půjdeme.
A nyní, pokud použijeme tuto notaci, můžeme přepsat vektor, jehož druhou mocninu Euklidovské normy bereme, abychom dostali pravděpodobnost pro
měření každého řetězce y.
Děláme to proto, abychom viděli,
jaké jsou koeficienty pro každý jednotlivý standardní bázový stav, a to není jasné z
tohoto výrazu právě zde,
protože obecně můžeme
mít více voleb x dávajících nám stejný řetězec f(x).
V podstatě vše, co děláme,
je rozdělení součtu přes x tím, že nejprve sečítáme přes všechna
z v oboru hodnot f,
a poté uvnitř tohoto součtu sčítáme přes všechna x ve vzoru z, nebo přesněji,
vzoru množiny
obsahující řetězec z.
To nám umožňuje nahradit f(x) hodnotou z uvnitř ketu tady.
A součet přes všechny různé řetězce
x, na které f přiřadí každé z, jsou shromážděny do
koeficientu pro každý ket.
V podstatě dáváme řetězce do košů, sčítáme přes koše, a poté sčítáme přes
řetězce v každém koši,
WEBVTT
ale to je ekvivalentní prostému
sčítání přes všechny řetězce.
Takže skutečně dostaneme výraz, který je ekvivalentní
tomu, se kterým jsme začali,
a nyní můžeme vypočítat
druhou mocninu Euklidovské normy.
Je to jen součet druhých mocnin absolutních hodnot
koeficientů, a tak dostaneme tento výraz právě zde
pro naše pravděpodobnosti.
Samozřejmě si dej
čas na ověření, pokud si to chceš udělat, chvíli trvá, než si na všechno zvykneš
a dokážeš provádět
tyto výpočty, a čím více praxe si dáš, tím jednodušší to bude.
Dosud jsme skutečně
nevyužili příslib v Simonově problému vůbec.
Naše analýza těchto pravděpodobností vlastně funguje pro jakoukoli funkci f, ale nyní je čas přemýšlet konkrétně o Simonově
problému.
Věci rozdělíme na stejné dva případy
jako předtím.
Prvním případem je, že s
je řetězec samých nul, a druhým případem je, že
s není řetězec samých nul.
V prvním případě, kdy
s je řetězec samých nul, jsou věci poměrně jednoduché.
V tomto případě, jak jsme viděli dříve, platí, že f je prostá funkce, takže existuje jediný řetězec x,
který je přiřazen na každý ze
řetězců z v oboru hodnot f.
To dělá absolutní hodnotu na druhou součtu přes tyto řetězce rovnou 1, protože je v součtu pouze
jeden člen,
je to buď plus 1 nebo minus 1, ale nezáleží na tom, které, protože bereme
absolutní hodnotu na druhou, a tak dostaneme jedničku.
V oboru hodnot f je 2 na n
prvků, a to víme, protože f je prostá, takže pro každý vstupní řetězec je v oboru hodnot jeden řetězec.
A pokud vyhodnotíme celý výraz, zjistíme, že každý řetězec y se vyskytuje s pravděpodobností
jedna ku dvěma na n.
Jinými slovy,
měření nám dají řetězec y zvolený rovnoměrně náhodně.
To se možná nezdá příliš užitečné, ale ve skutečnosti budeme schopni
rozlišit toto chování od chování, které dostaneme v případě,
že s není řetězec samých nul, a brzy uvidíme, jak to funguje.
Pro tuto chvíli jednoduše pozorujeme, že pokud
f splňuje příslib v Simonově problému v případě, že s je řetězec samých nul,
pak výsledkem měření je rovnoměrně náhodný řetězec.
Nyní se přesuneme na druhý případ, kdy je příslib
splněn pro řetězec s, který není řetězec samých nul.
V tomto případě, jak jsme diskutovali dříve, každý řetězec z v oboru hodnot f má právě dva řetězce, které na něj přiřazují,
protože každý řetězec má partnera, a každý pár partnerů
přiřazuje na nějaký jedinečný řetězec, a konkrétně partner každého řetězce
je řetězec, který dostaneme XORováním se s.
Takže pokud zvolíme jakýkoli řetězec
z v oboru hodnot f, a dáme název w jednomu ze
řetězců, na které f přiřadí z,
pak XOR w se s je
druhý řetězec, který se přiřazuje na z.
Při pohledu na pouze jeden člen v našem součtu odpovídající jakémukoli řetězci z v oboru hodnot, který máme na mysli,
vidíme, že ho můžeme
zapsat explicitněji, jak máme právě zde.
Ve vzoru z máme dva řetězce, w a w XOR s.
Takže součet můžeme zapsat,
jak vidíš na obrazovce, a nyní můžeme vytknout faktor
záporné 1 na mocninu w.y.
Tento faktor bude
buď plus 1 nebo minus 1, takže po absolutní hodnotě zmizí,
a co nám zbyde, je
tento výraz právě zde.
Detaily zde nejsou všechny ukázány, a není nutně zřejmé, že to takto funguje, ale můžeš ověřit, že tyto
dva výrazy jsou si rovny
vrácením se k definici
binárního skalárního součinu a přemýšlením o tom, co se stane, když jsou tyto věci v
exponentu záporné 1,
podobně jako tomu bylo pro
problém Bernstein-Vazirani.
Konečně tento výraz
rozdělíme na dva případy.
Je 4, když binární skalární součin
s a y je 0, a je 0, když binární
skalární součin s a y je 1.
Všimni si zejména toho, že
zde není vůbec žádná závislost na w nebo z, záleží pouze na s a y.
Důvod, proč se to děje, je
kvůli velmi specifické a speciální povaze příslibu.
V podstatě proto byl příslib formulován tímto způsobem, aby to všechno takto vyšlo.
Opět, každý řetězec má partnera, který dostaneme XORováním s
tímto jedním skrytým řetězcem s,
a to je to, co to všechno způsobuje.
Nyní se můžeme vrátit k
výrazu pro pravděpodobnosti a dosadit.
Když s není řetězec samých nul, v oboru hodnot f je 2 na n minus 1
prvků,
což je polovina
počtu vstupních řetězců, a dosazením hodnot, které jsme právě vypočítali, dostaneme tento vzorec právě zde.
Takže tentokrát y není
úplně náhodný řetězec, ale spíše y je rovnoměrný přes přesně polovinu n-bitových řetězců,
WEBVTT
a konkrétně je rovnoměrný přes ty řetězce, které mají binární skalární součin rovný 0 se s.
Nyní, když víme, jak circuit
pro Simonův algoritmus funguje a konkrétně jaké
jsou pravděpodobnosti pro různé výsledky měření,
zbývá vysvětlit, jak nám to pomáhá řešit Simonův problém.
Shrňme, co jsme se právě dozvěděli: pokud funkce f splňuje příslib v Simonově problému,
když je skrytý řetězec s
řetězec samých nul, dostaneme z měření úplně náhodný
řetězec,
kde každý n-bitový řetězec
y je stejně pravděpodobný.
Pokud na druhou stranu funkce f splňuje příslib pro jiný řetězec s, jeden, který se nerovná
řetězci samých nul,
dostaneme náhodný řetězec y mající binární skalární součin
rovný 0 se s, a mezi všemi těmito řetězci
je každý y stejně pravděpodobný.
Ale nikdy nedostaneme řetězec y mající binární skalární součin
rovný 1 se s.
Otázka zní: „Je to dostatek informací
k určení s?" A odpověď, jak jsem
již naznačil, je ano,
za předpokladu, že spustíme circuit
dostatečně mnohokrát.
Konkrétně předpokládejme,
že spustíme circuit k krát, kde K se rovná n plus r,
kde r je nějaké číslo, které bude řídit
pravděpodobnost, že s obnovíme.
Například pokud
zvolíme r rovno 10, budeme úspěšní s
pravděpodobností větší než 99,9 %,
takže r nemusí být příliš velké.
Obecně je pravděpodobnost selhání menší než pravděpodobnost
hodu spravedlivou mincí r krát a pokaždé hlavy.
Takže pokud 99,9 % nestačí,
vezmi r rovno 20, a šance na selhání je
menší než jedna ku milionu,
nebo zvolte r, které
ti vyhovuje. Nelze zaručit správné řešení, ale pravděpodobnost chyby lze učinit zanedbatelnou
pro všechny praktické účely.
Zde pojmenováváme
tyto řetězce y1 až yk, kde používáme horní indexy pro jejich pojmenování,
jen abychom si vyhradili dolní indexy pro odkazování na jednotlivé
bity těchto řetězců.
Takže to nejsou exponenty
ani nic takového, to jsou jen jména, která dáváme těmto k řetězcům.
Každý má délku n, protože jsme je dostali
spuštěním circuit pro Simonův algoritmus.
Takže si můžeme zapsat
jednotlivé bity těchto k řetězců, jak vidíš právě zde.
Nyní vytvoříme matici m, kde každý prvek této matice je bit, a tyto bity dostaneme z řetězců,
které jsme právě změřili, přesně jak je ukázáno tady.
Tato matice má k řádků a n sloupců, a všechny její prvky jsou binární hodnoty.
Nevíme, co je s. To je to, co se snažíme najít, ale jen si na chvíli představ, že bychom s věděli,
a vytvořili bychom sloupcový
vektor z bitů s, přesně jak je ukázáno tady.
Kdybychom tento vektor vynásobili m a poté vzali výsledek modulo 2, nebo jiným způsobem jak to říci,
je, že nahradíme sčítání
exkluzivním OR, pak nutně
dostaneme nulový vektor.
To proto, že každý ze
prvků tohoto výsledného vektoru není nic jiného než binární skalární součin s
s jedním z řádků m.
Pokud s je náhodou řetězec samých nul, vždy dostaneme nulový vektor z binárního skalárního součinu.
A pokud s není řetězec samých nul, dostaneme toto z toho, co
víme o pravděpodobnostech pro řetězce y1 až yk.
Konkrétně binární skalární součin se s je vždy nula pro všechny tyto řetězce.
Jednoduchý způsob, jak to říci, je, že tento vektor
tvořený z bitů s je vždy v nulovém prostoru matice m,
za předpokladu, že veškerou
aritmetiku děláme modulo 2, ale samozřejmě nevíme, co je s,
to se snažíme najít.
Ale co můžeme udělat, je vypočítat
nulový prostor této matice m, opět modulo 2.
Konkrétně to můžeme udělat pomocí techniky
Gaussovy eliminace, což je postup, který se často vyučuje
v úvodních kurzech lineární algebry.
Funguje to perfektně dobře, když veškerou aritmetiku děláme modulo 2, a může to být provedeno poměrně
efektivně s počítačem.
A pokud vypočítáme nulový prostor m, s ohledem na konkrétní způsob, jakým bylo těchto k řetězců náhodně zvoleno,
budeme schopni obnovit s s pravděpodobností větší než
1 minus 2 na záporné r.
Konkrétně to, co uvidíme s pravděpodobností větší než
1 minus 2 na záporné r, je, že nulový prostor
obsahuje nulový vektor,
jak vždy platí pro každou matici, stejně jako vektor odpovídající s, ať je to nulový vektor nebo ne.
A co je nejdůležitější, žádné jiné vektory se
v nulovém prostoru nevyskytnou.
Ve skutečnosti to není příliš těžké dokázat, i když to zde nebudu probírat do detailu.
WEBVTT
Myšlenka je, že pokud máme
nějaký jiný řetězec, který není nulový
vektor a není to s, pak každý z náhodných
řetězců y1 až yk
ho v podstatě s pravděpodobností polovina
vyřadí z nulového prostoru.
Takže po k výstřelech není
vůbec pravděpodobné, že přežije, a ve skutečnosti je nepravděpodobné, že přežije žádný z řetězců, které tam nepatří.
A velmi jednoduchý fakt
z teorie pravděpodobnosti, známý jako union bound, lze
použít k jeho prokázání.
Nevysvětlil jsem zde všechny
detaily, ale doufám, že chápeš myšlenku, že výpočtem nulového prostoru modulo 2 této matice m
s velmi velkou pravděpodobností obnovíme s, a takto Simonův algoritmus
řeší Simonův problém.
Zbývá jen jedna věc
říci o Simonově problému, a to se týká klasické
obtížnosti tohoto problému,
tedy kolik dotazů potřebuje klasický dotazovací algoritmus k řešení Simonova problému?
Odpověď je: hodně, obecně.
Existují různá přesná
vyjádření, která lze učinit o klasické
obtížnosti tohoto problému, a zde je jedno z nich.
Pokud máme jakýkoli pravděpodobnostní
dotazovací algoritmus a ten algoritmus provede méně než 2 na mocninu n ku 2
minus 1, minus 1 dotazů,
tedy počet dotazů,
který je exponenciální v n, pak tento algoritmus selže
při řešení Simonova problému,
s pravděpodobností alespoň polovina.
Někdy může být prokazování
výsledků nemožnosti jako tento velmi náročné, ale tento není příliš těžké dokázat
pomocí elementární
pravděpodobnostní analýzy.
V tomto videu to nebudu probírat a zaměřím se
pouze na intuici za tím.
Snažíme se najít skrytý řetězec s, ale dokud nedotazujeme funkci na dvou řetězcích mající
stejnou výstupní hodnotu,
dostaneme velmi omezené
informace o s.
V podstatě se dozvíme jen to,
že skrytý řetězec s není exkluzivní OR žádných dvou různých
řetězců, na které jsme se dotazovali,
a pokud dotazujeme funkci na méně než tomto počtu dotazů, stále zůstane hodně voleb s,
které nebyly vyloučeny.
Toto není formální důkaz,
ale to je základní myšlenka.
Takže souhrnně, Simonův algoritmus nám poskytuje pozoruhodnou výhodu kvantových oproti klasickým
algoritmům v rámci dotazovacího modelu.
Konkrétně Simonův
algoritmus řeší Simonův problém s počtem dotazů, který je lineární v počtu vstupních
bitů n naší funkce,
zatímco jakýkoli klasický algoritmus,
i pravděpodobnostní, musí provést počet
dotazů exponenciální v n,
aby vyřešil Simonův problém s rozumnou pravděpodobností úspěchu.
Je pravda, že Simonův problém je poněkud umělý problém, který pravděpodobně nikdo
skutečně nechce řešit,
ale to je vedlejší. Někdy je potřeba myšlenky rozvíjet, než jsou uvedeny do praxe.
A skutečně, Peter Shor jasně uvedl, že to byl Simonův algoritmus, který inspiroval jeho nyní
slavný kvantový algoritmus
pro faktorizaci celých čísel, který uvidíme za pár lekcí.
A to je konec Lekce 5.
V této lekci jsme se podívali na
dotazovací model výpočtu a viděli jsme postupný sled příkladů
kvantových algoritmů
vykazujících výhody oproti klasickým algoritmům
v rámci tohoto modelu.
Ve skutečnosti je toho mnohem více
známého o dotazovacím modelu a kvantových algoritmech pro jiné problémy, o nichž jsem nemluvil.
Takže pokud ti tento
model připadá zajímavý, je toho ještě hodně
co se naučit.
Naším dalším krokem bude odklonit se
od dotazovacího modelu směrem k modelu výpočtu,
který je reprezentativnější
pro druhy problémů, které doufáme řešit v praxi.
Doufám, že se ke mně přidáš v Lekci 6, kde se zaměříme hlavně na
položení základů pro studium kvantových algoritmů.
A odtud se přesuneme na některé
konkrétní kvantové algoritmy, včetně Shorova algoritmu
pro faktorizaci celých čísel
v dalších lekcích. Nashledanou!